you've heard of the power breakfast that
ritual gathering of wealth and influence
every morning the Lowe's Regency on
Manhattan's Park Avenue now there's a
new power experience with a well-groomed
dealmaker I'm our chats gram here for
Power Hour that's right the Power Hour
as much pampering as you can squeeze
into sixty New York minutes for me today
that's a haircut
my first ever manicure and the bite of
lunch you know a lot of people come
specially men double vodka and have the
driver waiting to say like I need to go
before they even arrive Julianne Ferrell
is the man behind the Power Hour when I
walk I walk like an architect Ferrell
has a famous following to debunk a trump
Winnick Paltrow even tennis star Rafael
Nadal you know every single time I have
catchment areas win the US Open by now
you've probably guessed Pharrell bring
some pricing power to the Power Hour his
signature cut cost $1,000 I think today
we sell more than a haircut use some
experience for years Pharrell salon was
on Tony Madison Avenue he moved in May
after the Tisch family carved out 10,000
square feet for him in the newly
renovated Regency I used to I always
said we never never leave Madison
Michael address write great address the
best I think is to be part of the quiche
family for me to know know Jonathan
Tisch is chairman of the Louis
Corporation and a longtime client of
Julian Pharrell it was his idea to
include a high-end spa the hotel's one
hundred billion dollar makeover I was
sitting in Julian's chair one day a
couple years ago and I said we are
thinking about making a major commitment
to creating a salon would you be
interested and so they became partners
how much of a difference can a facility
like this Julian's name and reputation
and talents make to a Regency we think
it makes a big difference it tells the
story of the hundred million dollar
enhancement in ways other than a new
Lobby new carpet new wall coverings but
I wonder is $1,000 too much to ask for a
haircut I don't set Julian's pricing
Julian knows his clientele he doesn't
set my hotel prices I don't set his
haircut prices when you check out we
think that you'll be pleased with that
return on expectations the same is true
with your experience at the Julian
Ferrell salon voila voila
so metal night now you're ready for
business you can see